[Music]
what up everybody did you guys know that
we now also have a podcast the same
content but night to listen with the
ears instead of getting distracted with
your eyeballs so go into the description
below click on one of those links and
then you can put it in your ears and you
can go running you can go [ __ ] you can
go say what's up to your mom you can do
all kinds of [ __ ] without being
distracted and don't forget you're in it
don't forget to rate it five stars even
though your mom could be talking [ __ ] to
you by [ __ ] you [ __ ] five stars the JK
news if you're a [ __ ] and listening
to a podcast you're gonna be single
really soon and if you're not listening
to the YouTube videos that's also where
unless you premature ejaculate like me
and he lives in the day of Goggins and
makes it last longer
alright this week we've got Bart's weird
BJ bruises adorable daredevil and cheese
chase [ __ ] brews funny names yeah she
needs to lay off the teeth who said it
was this she oh he needs to lay oh [ __ ]
well if it was a guy I would be like he
needs to shave his stubble mmm
all right so there was this 47 year old
man that went to his dentist and his
dentist noted that he sawed off his
dentist no so he and if you did so what
why are you judging oh yeah so then the
dentist noticed a crack in his filling
and his tooth and he also noticed that
there was a circular shaped lesion on
his soft platelet so the roof of their
thought did tell his dentist that he had
a history of marijuana and cocaine and I
he was exceptionally active with men oh
if you like to suck a lot of dick dude
best face [ __ ] is all about filming
yeah that's literally just grabbing by
the [ __ ] ears
whoa the tip of the dick Wow
that is the [ __ ] tip of the day it
straight up to smash it back yeah that
was a very consistent stroke yeah it's
not a bunch of circles like this like
overlapping circle it's the same one it
that means as he's doing he's adjusting
his jaws and facing us Jose yep or it
might be him giving calibrating it yeah
exactly like a printer what the [ __ ]
level on his head of [ __ ] like the
bubble level on is for it yeah what a
conversation to have with your dentist
yeah you know do a little coke here
smoke a little weed suck a lot of dick
just then just a usual can you get
ringworm in your mouth no right your
mouth you can get anywhere dude right
have that happen to you is there a
picture of the [ __ ] Oh dogs is
gonna say no picture somehow I pictured
like the mohawk sucker read like the
most normal looking dude like like a
like if you think of a salesman like a
corporate guy that's what I pictured
really Oh consider cocaine that's why
cocaine marijuana and you can afford
going to the dentist well the last time
you want I do but I ain't got the time
to what what it's a Dior do you die I
haven't gone in a minute but I trust my
teeth I don't need a second opinion I
got trust that can't be broken
[Laughter]
oh really warp okay anyway so then the
dentist told this man to just stop
having oral sex he's addicted to it he
[ __ ] add an oral sex along with coke
and marijuana that's like that's it on
his addiction list yeah so then compute
later after he stopped having oral sex
the illusion went away so before so
you've been sucking a lot every day I
want to see what like uh if porn stars
have that gene right because you know
poor stars that do a lot of anal they
got a little protruding butt skin coming
out of their [ __ ] booty hole or
something
it's like wrinkling outside and it's not
a hemorrhoid and I'm like man that booty
so loose that she's not it looks like a
grandma's [ __ ] armpit [ __ ] Dingle
dangle big lead angle II sounds like a
[ __ ] like southern magician
technically yes so they're saying that
this is not the first time that this
type of injury has been reported a lot
of people like sucking dick wait why is
it an injury
it's a lesion it's an open wound oh is
that yeah it's a Legionnaire so they're
saying that there was a study of 132 sex
workers in Peru noted that 17 had oral
lesions and hard dick because the the
platelet of your mouth is already hard
right so that means that the tip of the
dick has to be harder than the platelet
in the mouth that hurt that [ __ ]
well the third the thrusting might just
be hard like just repetitive well that
area if you touch it it's a little more
tender than
middle part yeah I don't think you read
you with your tongue I'm not I'm not a
fan of getting deep throat for the
record so it's cool wait get it right I
don't I don't like getting deputy foot
now you like getting the or giving I
think he just means that girls giving
him deep oh oh not him giving T soon Oh
how the [ __ ] is going on right now man
this is a weird day huh what's the
difference
mmm just it's it's not what it looks
like it doesn't feel what it looks like
well my dicks not big saw regular
brought [ __ ] a deep throat baby stop
deep go together I don't have a choice
alright that's all I got you have a bad
experience no no like a girl can use
like more movements with the lips and
the mouth I mean in the in the tongue
it's it's an N like if the dick head is
back here there's not much going on it's
kind of just snug but there's not a lot
like so if there's like is this if
there's a big head right yeah if this is
the big head then it's like it this is
the mouth with the [ __ ] lips and the
tongue and it's going like that right
but then if it's all the way down here
and it's nothing but [ __ ] throat so
it's just snug unless they know unless
they have talented tonsils yeah unless
they know how to and it's like [ __ ]
vibrating
you do good to thoughtful yeah not my
thing
all right did you guys hear about the
raccoon all my [ __ ] god yes why why
was it such a big deal I was like Dina
is not like nothing's going on in that
town the raccoon knows climbing like a
25 story building wasn't just that town
it it trends it was trending on Twitter
that's what I'm saying so it started
there so nothing's clearly happening
there because they decided to put that
right and then the rest of the world
jumped in I was just like I'm an animal
lover right and I'm like yeah I felt bad
for but as big as it got like I'm like
I'll make more important [ __ ] yeah I can
see where you're coming from because if
I saw that right be like well that's
crazy and I move on with my day
you grew an attachment though because
there lasted over so so many hours and
then apparently that raccoon this shit's
better than a high-speed chase by the
way then i koude was stuck for two days
in the neighboring building and then
when you try to bring that record down
that's when you started scaling up the
one of the tallest buildings that they
have in st. Paul Minnesota so here's the
photo this blue cracks me the [ __ ] up so
can you guys see the raccoon here oh my
god even no raccoons can like that yeah
holy [ __ ] that's insane
cuz it's a curved cuz I thought it was a
flat wall cuz I'm like how is he
gripping it oh but it's curved I don't
think it makes a difference Julia um
it's a wall and he's [ __ ] killing it
I get what she's saying cuz it's a
little bit more surgical so he could I
wonder what's going through his mind
like what's what's the goal here like
what are you trying to get a folder
saying that they Hugh might have been
trying to get some like nests there were
like some birds nests some sort of nests
yeah eyes like that so here's like oh my
little buddy go nothing looks okay
everyone kept calling rocket like yeah
accordian yeah guys badass it is rocky
oh you did you look at all this building
is badass but
raccoons are [ __ ] vicious everyone's
like I love one but they'll [ __ ] rip
your face off and I don't think people
understand how vicious right but they
people do have pets they do but you had
like any I mean it's still an animal you
know what I mean and they're not
domesticated they're really not I dare
[ __ ] vicious they [ __ ] up dogs good
and fast do you think we got thumbs and
[ __ ] yeah like even those that
domesticated them like they would
actually go in and create holes in the
wall and just climb within like the
house model and it like they'll cut out
through the cabinet both they're like
underneath the senior bandits dude yeah
they terrorize the house they're
adorable but I just saw rapcon sitting
on a couch with a bunch of popcorn on
his belly eating that [ __ ] watching TV I
want you out of my house I don't want a
son like that or a kid like that that
who looks like a zero that the the
Mexican [ __ ] zero guy
Zorro zero the hero zero is his loser
teenage son do you say zero in Spanish
Zorro
Sara oh no spell differently oh hey what
the [ __ ] you know why didn't get what he
was saying he go you know zero zero that
goes around and then put zeros on
people's stuff yes a gay wizard maybe it
was a parody for like a math show or
something then it was okay is it a
cartoon or is it like a live actor
Antonio Banderas dude no I've seen that
what I was thinking about the cartoon as
a kid it is a cartoon he always went off
in the fog you were off you meant zero
the hero I mean this is a pops up I
don't know he doesn't look like a
raccoon and he doesn't look like he's
doing it
wait that's not Sesame Street that's new
that's not the one I'm talking about
okay that's because the one you're
talking about doesn't exist no it's not
here that's what I think it means on Raw
no it's not a dog are you talking about
the Sailor Moon [ __ ] mr. moody I
don't know never lies oh yeah talking
about Robin from back we're gonna forget
it don't waste your time anyway
let's go back to the please please if
you guys know a rack of a cartoon that
looks like a rack please help me out
here let us know I know about [ __ ] a
[ __ ] with me I know this [ __ ] I saw
her she has a kid I thought I could meet
it up to the roof around 2:30 a.m. and
he was caught after like bait left out
some cat food in a cage so they finally
caught him and they released him into a
resident who looks like he has no hands
he only has back feet look it looks like
cute though he's super he's like a
chicken he looks like a chicken like a
quail or something you don't want to own
another pan oh no thanks
yeah you don't you're three but you have
right now there's so [ __ ] desperate
for attention I call yeah dude you
should have saw meatloaf when we went
camping dude that full looked like he
was in prison for 40 years he finally
came out he's not even that you know
what it is his dumbass likes to bite
like certain witches or whatever and
then he bites it raw so we have to keep
his cone on him and then we want to take
it off and then when we do he bites
again the new one in the [ __ ] new one
we're like what the [ __ ] bro like we
want a [ __ ] he wasn't doing that done
camping that maybe he was just out I
think yeah I think it was mr. s down all
right last stories there is this
tradition in England where they write
back where they roll down a hill chase
oh my god that is awesome gee I love
cheese wheel it makes me so happy
really you saw it yeah I couldn't stop
watch her here's a here's a clip of just
tradition amazing this is so [ __ ] I
want to sit there and just watch it
happen there we go that plum
why is that go that's commit me right
there what doll [ __ ] people trying to
get whiplash with the [ __ ] that was
pants is coming off dude down you should
do that that's a real man's thing oh my
god that's commitment
oh what's the atleta sysm about falling
down a mountain none of them know how to
roll a straight up though everyone is
out of control
a hundred percent I would [ __ ] win I
do that every [ __ ] day that's good
from his bed to his bathroom ha ha ha
you would win but break every single
bone that legit is every morning for me
so I don't know what the [ __ ] I don't
know what times already how do you even
train for that easy right just [ __ ]
just the 200ms cam in my house follow me
where you go do you think stunt doubles
would be able to successfully do that oh
yeah dude easy it's a fifty percent
grade steep and it's not even yeah you
could tell some oil is a baby follow me
[ __ ] lunch oh I hope they pull all
the rocks out battle [ __ ] son how
would that happen I didn't know that
that was an actual thing because I don't
know if you guys ever played this game
but it's like a long time ago but it's
called Neopets no what is it
I remember hearing about it yeah
so is there like a tamagotchi no old
[ __ ] I don't know it's just like
Oh zero we know it's like a game that
you can play online but it's like it's
very interactive so you can play with
people all the way like around the world
but it's pretty much kind of like in a
2d format so it's not necessarily like
maplestory where it's like an RPG but
it's just basically like you have your
own pets that you take care of yeah and
you can participate in different events
oh I'm gotcha yeah something filler like
Sims Pokemon yeah kind of like that yeah
so what does this have to do so the new
pets are supposed to be global right so
it's like you're in a global world and
so in one of the worlds that you go into
you can participate in this game to win
a free wheel cheese cheese roll is what
it's called so that's in that game yeah
but you have [ __ ] dogs Paulie no no
no it's just like hey please like the
cheese wheel game and then you just see
your player just running down the hill
but they're not falling yes apparently
first recorded Chester cheese roll
happened in 1826 but they're saying that
just could have started even before that
yeah I mean it makes sense that had
those that I feel like they were all
famished that was the only cheese in
that town well that's what I'm saying it
makes sense back then right like legit
there's well there was nothing around
you know how its start I think it's kind
of cool I think you know how the game
started is there was a cheese [ __ ]
merchant and then his cheese fell and
all these hungry peasants were like
cheese and then they [ __ ] ran after
it and then the one that tumbled down
and grabbed it first they got the cheese
yeah Finders Keepers that's some sad
[ __ ] fun let's keep dropping cheese down
is there a weird Mexican tradition like
that
I'm sure there's weird ones but for I
don't know if I think it's weird because
it might just be normal already you
might have to ask question is it that
funny though where people just falling
down yeah some say like something we're
like
I can't think of anything we should make
one up like how do you train to look
like you're not in control yeah that's
me I think that's what I like about it
cuz you have to commit to cuz you see
some people kind of holding back and
they're like on their butts going to
that [ __ ] was crazy I was like take me
deep dude I legit saw somebody's a hip
bone in their mouth I didn't know you
could do that you just gotta find that
irresistible they're irresistible thing
for each culture so like why people love
their cheese they'll go crazy for it
yeah risking their lives right hmm you
gotta throw a couple of pennies down the
hill and the Asian people just go right
just quarter quarter of all the agents
are [ __ ] chasing after it free haircut
roll or something there you go coupon
roll free t-shirt roll yeah
[Music]